[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you oh my gosh
again what a thank you what a great
audience we have and hey we made it to
may
i think that's an accomplishment it's
may 1st for those of you still
clinging to the concept of time
every i tell you every morning i go in
the bathroom i sit on the toilet and
think different [ __ ]
same day
you know yeah i am so sorry i ever dared
that guy in wuhan to eat that bat
worst bar bet ever i'm telling you
but uh here's some kind of good news uh
trump's
approval rating is way down which means
that america
may finally have reached turd immunity
[Applause]
and yeah he's not by you know who else
not popular this week mike pence
not popular went to the mayo clinic
everyone was wearing a mask of course
it's the mayo clinic or everywhere
and he did not have a mask mike pence
said no it's okay i've been tested and
besides
they're called bare-faced lies
trump was very upset this week because
the new york times printed this article
that said that he spends
it certainly doesn't sound like the
trump i know spends all
morning in bed watching television and
eating french fries and
mark meadows mark meadows his uh chief
of staff said that is some
[ __ ] right there that is fake news
this man barely spends 10 minutes for
lunch
and he says i can prove it and i've got
the tape
[Applause]
yeah don't don't [ __ ] with lunch trump
this week this i love
you know the war powers act which is at
his disposal uh
he could use it for you know masks
ventilators testing
he used it this week to make sure that
the meatpacking plants
were kept open cause meat
now it's personal
you step on donald trump's meat hose and
[ __ ] just got real
but here's something kind of good
uh dr fauci says in his words that he is
very optimistic about this experimental
new drug
called rem deservier i think it's the
pronunciation close
okay rem whatever captioning not
available
i this
incomparably stupid man actually
suggested and he's the president of the
united states i don't know if you know
that
actually suggested this week that
people ingest cleaning disinfectants
and his voters started calling poison
control centers to see if that was
okay deplorables
they're the unbleachables
so it was interesting that this is the
week then that hillary
chose to um endorse
joe biden and all i could think of was
really
what took you this long i mean
he hasn't even had an opponent for a
month yeah hillary said it was a close
decision but at the end of the day she
broke for the guy who doesn't urge
angry mobs to lock her up
but uh look things are changing in
america states
are starting to open up for business
again georgia
leading the way they have opened up the
tattoo parlors
and the beauty salons in the south what
they call the high-tech sector
and it's good to see that in georgia
things are becoming normal again
and when i say becoming normal i mean
being able to get a tattoo of
jesus wrestling a snake
um so if you're in bowling alleys
in georgia if you're in georgia bowling
alleys are open
uh barbershops and tattoo parlors
because what could be safer
businesses than ones involving razors
needles and sticking your fingers in
other people's balls
you